have you ever been set up like on a by a
friend like on a blind date I heard that
you maybe had a one once and me too and
never again me too what was what what
happened mine was horrible you go I mean
and mine was horrible too yeah but uh
yeah I mean like he would just he just
like he like he ordered steaks as one
steak and then like cut it up into
little baby pieces
I don't
know and then it was like here you go
and I was like thank you what are you a
baby bird yeah no I know I was like do I
need a little like lobster fork for that
I don't know what I'm saying but that
was why it was splitting the steak
that's not exactly give me the option of
a side you know what I mean yeah or at
least on the first date like go big like
and it's like maybe years later you're
like we're trying to save you split the
steak yeah no jalapeno poppers yeah no I
love
yeah yeah so that didn't go well didn't
go well never again me neither never
again somebody set me up and I was like
this is the worst thing God invented it
is because then her man you can't like
if you can't like investigate them
beforehand especially too yeah oh this
was a time when I did it when there was
no social media because I'm old
apparently but um yeah there was no
social media you couldn't like Google
someone back then right yeah so it was
horrible I'll never do it again ever
again um so I did find out that you have
some kind of like hack though for on a
date that you found out from a makeup
artist
so it involved toilets okay it does it
doesn't have anything to do with dating
though but oh okay I had this makeup
artist once that appeared out of nowhere
like she like she just she I think she
was like maybe filling in for something
she's very mysterious and she like
appeared and like was very frazzled and
was doing my my eyebrows and she like
she like kind of fell in it and the
whole thing went like on my eye and she
was like I'm Gonna Leave it you know why
hot tip you can take off mascara better
when it's dry right okay so I was like
okay so like yeah he sounds like a good
plan right right and then and then it
was fine and she was funny and we had a
great time and then I did my thing and
in between sets she came up to me
like beckon toward me was like Laura
come here and I was like okay and so I
like and then she like Whispers into my
ear she's like did you know that toilet
seat covers are also an oil blotter for
your face and I was like why did you
call me off of set to whisper this to me
um
yeah and I never saw her again never saw
her again but yes I mean I I would
imagine that she's at an airport of her
choice right now just stocking up on
those things
um this is free yeah yeah exactly
someone's walking in and she's got the
whole thing like a runner yeah I know it
oh my God exactly I mean I guess she's
right they do feel I guess the same
consistency I guess material wise but I
don't know if I'd try it maybe in a
pinch I would try it every day you know
whatever yeah I am an oily person so
thanks for the tip
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]